zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
biontech meldet heute zwei milliarden
impfdosen werden in diesem jahr
ausgeliefert 1,3 waren ursprünglich mal
anvisiert und auch moderner der zweite
impfstoff der für deutschland und europa
zugelassen ist hat seine erste lieferung
nach europa geschickt und damit herzlich
willkommen ja die impfstoffe kommen auch
sie kommen allerdings langsam und der
impfstoff der da ist wird auch langsam
verteilt und nicht so schnell wie
vielleicht möglich und dann ist da noch
die frage nach der impfbereitschaft wo
geht's wo hapert's wer will und wer will
nicht was lässt menschen zweifeln und
was kann unternommen werden um die
impfbereitschaft zu steigern darüber
werde ich gleich reden mit frau
professorin cornelia betsch von der uni
erfurt und ihr könnt die fragen stellen
an die adresse die jetzt hier
eingeblendet wird zf heute - live at
zdf.de beginnen wollen wir in magdeburg
denn dort ist vor ort live für uns luisa
houben und zwar im impfzentrum das heute
aufgemacht hat aber viel los ist nicht
gerade oder nee allerdings mal davon
abgesehen dass es schon halb acht ist
ist dieses impfzentrum immer noch ein
bisschen im dornröschenschlaf könnte man
sagen hier ist nicht wirklich was los
denn magdeburg hat beschlossen das
impfzentrum noch nicht zu eröffnen
es gab bisher nur testläufe also es
wurden hier schon menschen geimpft aber
das waren mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter des rettungsdienstes also
hier die messehalle wurde umgebaut ist
es auch alles bereit und mit dem impfen
loszulegen aber tatsächlich geimpft
wurde hier noch niemand
das zeigt uns doch mal wie soll's denn
laufen wenn es läuft genau wir stehen
hier gerade im eingangsbereich des
zentrums da vorne in dieser bei dieser
tür
da werden die menschen kommen die einen
termin vereinbart haben das wird für
sachsen-anhalt online und auch über die
hotline funktionieren die registrieren
sich dann hier vorne kommen an sozusagen
und dann geht es in dieser aufklärungs
räume da gibt's meter gefunden und da
werden alle
fragen rund um die impfung gegen das
kronos beantwortet und zwar von diesem
bildschirm da vorne
es wird ein informations video geben das
wird ungefähr 15 minuten dauern
und da sollen die menschen aufgeklärt
werden über die impfung und dann geht es
immer den fall nach die hier auf dem
boden sind durch diesen im parcours
könnte man ihn wenn das es eigentlich
nicht zu verfehlen wo es lang geht es
gibt einen kleinen hinweis wenn man
nicht einverstanden ist mit dem mit der
impfung dann ist hier der letzte ausgang
da geht es zurück zum parkplatz für alle
anderen aber die sich dafür entscheiden
sich gegen das virus impfen zu lassen
geht es dann in eine der im kabinen und
davon gibt es hier in magdeburg zehn
stück das heißt es können zehn menschen
gleichzeitig geimpft werden
wir gehen mal in eine rein hier in
impfen 6 das nicht auch relativ
unspektakulär ausfindig
es ist ein tisch zwei stühle und hier
wird ärztin oder arzt sitzen und ein
rettungssanitäter und derjenige der
kämpft wird nimmt platz und bekommt die
spritze ergibt ein impfausweis abbekommt
stempel und aufkleber und das ist ja das
dauert keine minute das geht relativ
schnell
es sei denn es gibt auch noch fragen
finden vom impfling dann werden die auch
hier noch beantwortet also es ist nicht
so als wir mit dem video alles erledigt
wenn es noch fragen gibt dann gibt es
hier auch noch antworten ja und dann ist
das impfen eigentlich auch schon hat
sich es schon vorbei dann geht es
richtung wartebereich
denn nach dem impfen soll man ja 15 bis
20 20 minuten noch da bleiben um zu
schauen wie die menschen denn die
impfung vertragen
es gibt auch die möglichkeit sich dann
hier zum beispiel auch noch noch
hinzulegen sollte das für jemanden nötig
seien oder wenn auch jemand lieber
impfen im liegen geimpft werden möchte
geht das hier ja und dann geht es in den
wartebereich hier vorne stehen stühle
da kann man sich dann hinsetzen und
wartet dann darauf dass hier in diesem
kleinen verwaltungsbereich der der
vorbereitet wurde
alle dokumente noch einmal eingescannt
werden weil das land will ja auch wissen
wie viele menschen wurden geimpft das
wird dann hier dokumentiert so zu sagen
und dann nach ungefähr 35 minuten ist
das impfen vorbei in seiner in seiner
gänze und dann gehts da vorne wieder
raus
zum alter riesa danke das ist ja schon
mein erster eindruck den man sich da
wirklich machen kann wie man wirklich da
sozusagen durchgeschleust wird aber du
bist ja nicht nur in magdeburg unterwegs
wo also jetzt das impfzentrum aufmacht
du warst auch schon in sachsen anhalt an
anderen orten wie läuft denn da genau
ich war heute im burgenlandkreis da hat
das impfzentrum heute eröffnet aber die
eröffnung war auch nicht so pompös wie
ich sie mir auch vielleicht vorgestellt
hätte es waren zehn menschen die dort
heute geimpft wollen die hatten einen
termin bekommen haben den auch online
vereinbart und wurden dort heute geimpft
es ist ein langsamer staat würde ich mal
behaupten
man hat auch gemerkt die menschen dort
die ärztin und auch die die
rettungssanitäter müssen sich alle noch
ein bisschen einspielen es gab noch hier
und da fragen aber mit diesen zehn
personen für die auch ordentlich zeit
eingerechnet wurde hat man auch ein
bisschen erprobt wie könnte das
impfzentrum laufen wenn es dann
tatsächlich gut losgeht weil auch dort
zum beispiel können 450 menschen an
einem tag geimpft werden das heißt mit
zähnen ist die kapazität längst nicht
ausgeschöpft und visa danke für den
moment gekommen gleich zu dir zurück
beziehungsweise sollte nach magdeburg
wollen aber erst mal schauen wie denn
insgesamt der im staat in deutschland
angefangen hat und an läuft an seinen
stern mit den infos mit den impfstoffen
mit den spritzen gegen korona verbinden
viele große hoffnung das ende der krise
ist das ziel
es ist noch weit entfernt laut robert
koch institut gab es bislang gute
613.000 erste impfungen in deutschland
das sind 0,74 prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung extrem unterschiedlich
geht es voran in den bundesländern zeigt
der blick auf die impfquoten beispiel
sachsen viele neue infektionen aktuell
aber wenig geimpfte 0,49 prozent zum
vergleich das nachbarland sachsen-anhalt
1 prozent oder mecklenburg vorpommern
1,5 prozent das ist die corona in frage
die sich immer wieder verändert schon
bald soll neben dem biontech pfizer
wirkstoff ein weiteres mittel gespritzt
werden können
der impfstoff des us-herstellers
moderner wird ab morgen auch in
deutschland ausgeliefert
auch dazu so jetzt spreche ich mit
matthias bock sorgen sind wieder zurück
in magdeburg gleiches die kamera glaube
ich auch soweit sie sind von den
johannitern und damit beauftragt die
organisation die ganze verwaltung dieses
zentrums auf die beine zu stellen
ja warum hat es noch nicht auf sie
machen erst am 20 januar auf warum nicht
jetzt schon ja wir haben unsere ganze
kraft erst mal in die mobilen teams
gesteckt die aktuellen zahlen haben ja
bewiesen und auch gezeigt dass in den
pflegeheimen die größten probleme mit
kuwait 19 bestehen und wegen sex eine
handvoll in pflege brauchen wir hier
eigentlich so ein großes zentrum nicht
aufmachen aber das wird kommen da bin
ich mir sicher die nächsten impfungen
oder impfdosen sind angesetzt
und ich hoffe dass sie tatsächlich hier
auch in magdeburg eintreffen und dann
sind wir entsprechend vorbereitet dann
wurden noch wirklich voll loslegen
das heißt dann voll loslegen die sind
dann die kapazitäten die ihnen möglich
sind dort also wir können momentan auf
10 impft plätzen impfen wenn denn dann
die impfstoffe da sind und ein instinkt
wurde er vorhin auch schon gesagt
braucht ungefähr 35 minuten
ansonsten geht das hier rucki zucki also
ich denke das bekommen wir hin dass es
überhaupt nicht das problem
das problem ist aber vielleicht dass
viele alte menschen gar nicht wissen wie
sie haben so einen termin rankommen es
ist die möglichkeit sich online zu
registrieren oder anzurufen und einen
termin auszumachen
aber andere gehen auch davon aus na ja
man wird sich schon an mich wenden wenn
ich über 80 bin damit ich meinen termin
bekomme klappt es mit der
aufklärungsarbeit in ihren augen gut
das kann ich ihnen jetzt noch nicht
beantworten dann würde ich ihnen die
glaskugel schauen müssen ich hoffe dass
das klappt ich gehe auch fest davon aus
dass es klappt nicht alle 80 jährigen
sind alleine
viele haben auch noch verwandte bekannte
und da setzen wir einfach auch auf
nachbarschaftshilfe
es gibt auch viele pflegedienste und
dieser pflegedienste sind natürlich
genauso auch sensibilisiert mit dafür
sorge zu tragen dass ihre patienten
entsprechend auch geimpft werden durch
die hausärzte und die hausärzte immerhin
gibt es ja auch und die wissen wir auch
wo ihre patienten wohnen in welchem
zustand sie sind und den kommt dann auch
irgendwann eine ganz besondere aufgabe
zu
jetzt ist es ja nicht nur eine
logistische frage sondern die menschen
wollen ja auch sich in anführungszeichen
sicher fühlen und wohlfühlen bei dem was
dort passiert und wenn ich hier in die
in die meldungen schaue ist eigentlich
der überwiegende teil derer die uns hier
schreiben das ich skeptisch sind dass
sie erst mal abwarten wollen und dass
sie noch nicht glauben weil die
langzeitwirkung noch nicht hinreichend
untersucht worden seien
dass das alles so sicher ist was spüren
sie denn vor ort wenn sie beide menschen
sind wenn sie bei den älteren sind wenn
ja natürlich auch momentan ihre trupps
in die pflegeheime gehen
was erhoffen sie sich wie es dann läuft
und wie sie überzeugungsarbeit leisten
können also erstmal ist es natürlich
primär nicht unsere aufgabe
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten und ich
gebe zu auch ich musste erst ein
bisschen überzeugt werden dass es
natürlich neuland was wir hier betreten
die älteren menschen in den pflegeheimen
glaube ich sind der überzeugung dass das
wichtig und richtig ist weil sie
natürlich gemerkt haben wie sie so ein
stückchen auch auf den stationen
isoliert worden weil der besuch mal eben
nicht einfach rein kam weil sie
vielleicht muss vom fenster zuwinken
konnten sie erhoffen sich dadurch eine
besserung und was die reaktion und die
impfbereitschaft der bewohner angeht ist
das eine aber was das personal betrifft
ist das andere
die liegt momentan so bei 50 60 prozent
würde ich so grob überschlagen und ich
vermute mal ganz stark dass es da eine
steigende tendenz geben wird in den
nächsten wochen monaten
da vielleicht auch zu einer verbesserung
der zahlen beizutragen aber das ist
momentan noch gar nicht unser thema
eigentlich momentan jetzt für alle auch
gar nicht der impfstoff reichen haben
wie sehen sie das denn mit dem nachschub
was sind denn so ihre informationen die
sie bekommen das wirklich dafür genügend
stoff da ist um ihr zentrum dass sie da
jetzt auf die beine gestellt haben
wirklich dann auch sagt mal unter
volllast laufen zu lassen zu können
vor einigen tagen hat unser
oberbürgermeister lutz trümper in einer
pressekonferenz sehr klar zum ausdruck
gebracht dass bei dem zustand den wir
jetzt haben und es reicht eben in der
tat nicht weil ihnen nicht zu viel
impfstoff dass wir die volle
aufmerksamkeit auf die mobilen teams
setzen und eben nicht auf ein
impfzentrum deshalb kann ich ihnen
momentan noch nicht sagen was letztlich
in unserer nächsten lieferung wird um
die neunzehnter januar seien tatsächlich
an impfdosen ausgeliefert wird das macht
uns auch eigentlich ganz schwer zu
planen wir sind natürlich planer
natürlich würden alles bis ins detail
durch planen wollen wir können es aber
nicht wir werden ausgebremst weil wir
nicht wissen wie viel impfstoff kommt
liegt also nicht an der stadtverwaltung
die hat hervorragende arbeit geleistet
die hilfsorganisation die herren
beteiligt sind an hervorragende arbeit
geleistet nun brauchen wir tatsächlich
nur den impfstoff der nicht da ist aber
es ist ja auch nicht so dass er auch
warum liegt und nicht verteilt wird er
ist eben einfach noch nicht in der
großen kapazität für uns zur verfügung
und da werden wir einfach abwarten
müssen was die zukunft bringt so hören
wir ja auch dass noch ein werk demnächst
bald ans netz gehen soll
da hoffen wir uns natürlich eine
verbesserung der neue impfstoff kommt ja
jetzt auch 1200 dosen während in sachsen
anhalt verteilt werden davon 600 in
richtung universitätsklinikum halle die
anderen 600 an die uniklinik in richtung
magdeburg aber dort müssen auch zur
hälfte die rücklagen für die
zweitimpfung geschaffen werden so dass
sie dann uns von der großen zahl 1200
schon auf 300 in jeder
universitätsklinik hier in sachsen
anhalt ein fachunterricht berechnen
müssen das boxen danke führte im moment
viele informationen und großer magdeburg
dankeschön für ihren zeitgenossen zu
können ist das eine sich impfen lassen
zu wollen das ganz andere
das vorhin schon gesagt und ich schaue
hier in die zitate
da heißt es wirklich wenn man sich
impfen lassen will
warum sollte ich es tun was heißt es mit
den nebenwirkungen gibt es auch
psychische nebenwirkungen und eine ganze
menge mehr es ist ziemlich genau alles
in diese richtung
es sind ja nicht nur
verschwörungstheoretiker von denen da
oft die rede ist die sich irgendwie
dagegen aussprechen oder radikale
impfgegner sondern menschen die einfach
skeptisch sind die noch nicht wissen was
hat es mit diesem impfstoff tatsächlich
auf sich warum sollte ich als junger
mensch das machen heißt es auch hier in
den in den meldungen die ich hier
bekomme wenn es noch gar keine
langzeitstudien gibt normalerweise wäre
das die grundvoraussetzung dafür bei
einem anderen impfstoff das heißt es
hier wie gesagt unisono
ich spreche gleich mit frau professorin
cornelia betsch aber auch dazu erst noch
mal ein paar zahlen und fakten vorweg
impfstoffmengen impfstoff bestellungen
all das beschäftigt viele aktuell am
ende aber ist auch entscheidend die
impfbereitschaft wie viele menschen in
deutschland werden sich die spritze
abholen die antworten verändern sich
immer wieder zeigt beispielsweise eine
studie der uni erfurt 79 prozent wollten
sich impfen lassen im april 2020 ende
dezember sagten laut dieser befragung 57
prozent ja zur impfspritzen gegen korona
das sieht noch nicht so aus als ob sie
mich wirklich hören aber ich versuche es
noch einmal
doch sie nicken das ist gut hallo ich
fange mal an sie sind professorin an der
universität
sie sind auch psychologin vor allem und
sie sind gesundheits kommunikatorin auch
das ist glaube ich wichtig an der stelle
und klar zu machen wir führen ja kein
medizinisches gespräch über die
wirksamkeit von impfstoffen sondern wir
wollen wissen was die menschen denken
was sie überzeugt oder eben auch
zweifeln lässt wir haben vor den zahlen
aus ihrer studie gehört 57 prozent
würden sich impfen lassen
49 prozent waren es anfang dezember
worauf führen sie diesen anstieg zurück
leicht künstliche ja ich kann sie hören
aber ich hoffe das gilt umgekehrt
genauso sommer als die impfung noch ganz
weit weg war und hier mitten in der
ersten welle der panini saßen hat man
relativ nur in swatch es beobachtet
unter dem namen die impfstoffe immer
stärker in die medien und sie rückten
immer nie glücklich ging aber nirgends
bereitschaft runter und das ist ja
eigentlich ein paradox aus aber das ist
etwas das wir ganz häufig beobachten
können wenn etwas in weiter ferne ist
weiß ich nicht und ich war schlecht an
einen echten ort und wenn es dann aber
tatsächlich im nächsten tag ist dann
stellt mir praktisch an was dem alles im
blick steht stützen und so ähnlich ist
es bei den impfstoff auch als wir immer
näher rückte und das war nicht
zugelassen war
weil ich glaube ich muss leider mal
unterbrechen an der stelle weil wir
immer so thon aussetzer haben haben sie
die möglichkeit irgendwie noch anders
das mikrofon zu bedienen außer über
kopfhörer weil ich glaube da gibt es
gibt es immer leichter aussetzer
zumindest kommt das bei uns so an
[Musik]
also wir sehen wie sehen sie gut es
liegt am ton das ist schlecht merkt
fernsehen der ton gehört dazu
wir machen noch einmal einen neustart
ehrlich gerade und bauen die verbindung
noch einmal auf und hoffen dann dass das
mit dem ton funktioniert vielleicht was
sich an der stelle noch einmal zusammen
es wird also eine studie gemacht derzeit
laufen beobachtet von der uni erfurt
und da geht es darum wie hoch die
impfbereitschaft ist wir hatten anfang
dezember die zahl dass es 49 prozent der
befragten sind die bereit wären sich
gegen kuwait 19 impfen zu lassen
im april 2020 also vor einem knappen
jahr
da lag die zahl schon mal bei 79% wie
gesagt anfang dezember 49 ist aber jetzt
wieder gestiegen auf 57 prozent
da ist also ein deutlicher anstieg
innerhalb weniger wochen passiert aber
reicht das sozusagen eine bereitschaft
zu haben oder wie viel führt natürlich
auch dazu
die dann noch weiter ansteigen zu lassen
dass diejenigen sich dann auch
tatsächlich impfen lassen
florian klaus schreibt via facebook zum
beispiel klar dass ich mich impfen die
gefahr von nebenwirkungen ist um ein
vielfaches geringer als einen schweren
cupid 19 verlauf zu haben und mary delay
schreibt politiker sollten mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen aber sie sei
selbstverständlich dabei und er hat
schreibt warum sollte ich mich impfen
lassen wenn es noch keine
langzeitstudien gibt in die richtung
geht es gerade auch junge menschen sagen
es ist ja nicht geregelt und noch nicht
klar ob ich auch wenn ich geimpft bin
ich trotzdem das virus weiter reichen
kann an andere und kevin schreibt via
youtube transparent daten zu beschaffen
und publizieren sei das gebotene maß er
mit mitte 20 sei sehr froh nicht unter
den ersten in der impfung zu sein
aufgrund der noch unklaren datenlage das
jetzt mal hier als feedback via youtube
und ich frage noch mal nach oder höher
noch einmal nach wie es aussieht ob die
leitung nach erfurt steht zu frau b
ich sehe sie zumindest noch nicht
okay aber ich höre ich höre bei uns
klappt der ton zumindest da sind neue
neue kopfhörer im lauf und jetzt höre
und sehe sie auch wieder das ist gut und
versuchen uns noch mal okay gut ich habe
ein bisschen überbrückt ich habe die
zahlen nochmals zusammengefasst gut dass
es jetzt klappt das gute alte kabel ist
manchmal doch die beste variante
fassen wir also noch mal zusammen weil
ich glaube das ist wichtig und gegen
vorhin so ein bisschen unter es gab die
sehr hohe bereitschaft im april das war
theorie jetzt wo es darum geht sich
wirklich eine spritze setzen zu lassen
sieht es ein bisschen anders aus ich sag
noch mal anfang dezember waren es 49
prozent mittlerweile ist die zahl wieder
gestiegen auf neun und fünf auf 57%
worauf führen sie diesen konkreten
anstieg der zeit zurück wir haben die
ganze zeit gesehen dass die
impfbereitschaft gesunken ist und
gleichzeitig auch das vertrauen in die
impfung in die sicherheit der info- und
das hat den wendepunkt genommen der
zulassung der impfung
seitdem sind ja vielfach verhilft auch
in anderen ländern und beobachten also
es wird gekämpft und es passieren keine
schrecklichen dinge und deswegen steigt
im moment das vertrauen in die
sicherheit der impfung und deswegen
steigt auch insgesamt die
impfbereitschaft also dieser anstieg von
49 auf 57 prozent deutlich auf
gestiegenes vertrauen in die sicherheit
so zu sehen
was sind die entscheidenden faktoren für
impfbereitschaft also seit wir das
beobachten ist tatsächlich das vertrauen
nirgendwo mehr wichtigste faktor wir
sehen aber auch dass sie ist dass die
informations das informationsbedürfnis
sehr sehr hoch ist und das bleibt auch
das ist in manchen teilen sogar noch
gestiegen
also da ist immer noch viel
informationsbedürfnis da wichtig auch
der einfache zugang also wie einfach ist
es für mich ein impftermin zu bekommen
haben es in den filmen jetzt schon
gesehen
wir sehen jetzt dass es jetzt wo es
praktisch an die umsetzung geht
tatsächlich das auch eine barriere wird
es wird relevant begegnungs entscheidung
ist einfach oder schwer sein einen
termin zu kommen
bei all dem was ich sozusagen
berücksichtigen muss ob ich mich impfen
lassen will oder nicht das sind denn
tatsächlich ihn bekannt die ersten
motive die dafür aber auch die dagegen
sprechen
also im moment sitzen wir in einer
pandemie und da sind ja zwei
verschiedene arten sich zu weisen
möglich also dass eine wäre zu sagen ich
möchte jetzt die partie beenden deswegen
möchte ich mich impfen lassen und das
andere ist es ist ein möglicherweise
tödliches virus in umlauf und ich möchte
mich davor schützen und da mit con
verschiedene motivationslage verbunden
sein und wir sehen dass für die menschen
im moment dass tatsächlich am
wichtigsten ist ihre gesundheit zu
schützen und das ist auch sehr
relevanter aspekt denn wenn die meisten
leute eher die panini beenden wollen
würden mit ihrer impfung dann wäre man
vielleicht auch bereit das eine oder
andere risiko einzugehen kann man daran
denken wenn man schwerwiegende
erkrankung hat dann nimmt man vielleicht
auch ein medikament das nebenwirkungen
hat und so ähnlich wäre das hier auch
aber so ist es tatsächlich nicht den
menschen wollen ihre gesundheit schützen
und da guckt man natürlich ganz
besonders hin so wie bei anderen
impfungen eben auch wir haben einen
gesunden körper und da kommt etwas rein
und da sehen möchten wir möglichst kein
risiko eingehen
wie wollen denn und sollten denn die
menschen informiert werden um da klarer
zu sehen und nicht nur nach zu reden was
anderswo vielleicht gesagt wird sondern
sich selbst ein wirkliches bild zu
machen
auch wenn ich hier nochmal in die in die
meldungen und in die in das feedback so
schreibe da ist sagt mal viel von dem
üblichen was man immer wieder so ließ
und wo es dann auch sozusagen die
üblichen vorurteile gibt unabhängig
davon wie man zum impfen steht aber wo
ich jetzt nicht den eindruck gehabt dass
die leute sich wirklich informiert haben
sondern eben eher geneigt sind das was
man so hört auch in irgendeiner form
wiederzugeben das heißt also wie
erreicht man die menschen sich wirklich
mit der thematik auseinanderzusetzen und
abzuwägen
also erstmal ist es mit so informationen
wo man sich nicht so ganz sicher ist ob
das richtig ist oder falsch da sollten
wir damit umgehen wie mit krankheiten
auch also wir gehen ja auch nicht mit
dreckigen händen jemand die hand also
irgendwie sollten wir auch dinge von
denen bedenkt dass könnte schluss sein
einfach weitergeben
das ist so das erste damit wir auch
unsere informations umgebung
einigermaßen clean halten und das andere
ist es gibt einfach einen gewissen
anteil an der bevölkerung die der
bundesregierung nicht zwingend
hundertprozentig vertraut und deswegen
wird es nicht ausreichen immer nur
bessere und mehr informationen gute
informationen von der bundesregierung zu
verbreiten wir sehen dass insbesondere
auch skeptischere person gerne
informiert werden wollen über fernsehen
radio und über hausärzte das sind so die
wichtigen quellen
das zeigt auch so ein bisschen dass die
information alleine bei den menschen
vorbei kommen sollte also nicht jeder
möchte sich aktiv oder kann sich
vielleicht auch aktiv im internet
informieren sondern menschen möchten
gerne dass diese information ist alleine
bei ihm vorbeikommen und das andere sind
natürlich die ärzte jeder der in zukunft
zum hausarzt geht wird sicherlich im
spätestens im rausgehen noch mal fragen
was halten sie denn jetzt von der
impfung und da wird es ganz relevant
sein denn wissen uns anderer forschung
dass die ärzte sehr sehr starken
einfluss haben also die empfehlung die
zählt sehr stark und david ist wäre
gewarnt sein was die ärzte dann sagen
und dass sie natürlich gut informieren
denn man muss auch sehen diese
impfberatung bekommen sie nicht vergütet
da wäre es natürlich sinnvoll wenn sie
eine vorbereitete schriftstücke zum
beispiel aushändigen können um umfassend
zu informieren
genau das scheint mir ein wesentlicher
punkt zu sagen haben ja vorhin in
magdeburg gesehen dass wenn ich in einem
impfzentrum bin da wird mir nicht
einfach nur eine spritze injiziert und
fertig sondern da gibt es ein gespräch
da wird genau geschaut und dann geht das
alles ein gang
aber ich muss erst mal hin in so ein
impfzentrum und das andere ist was sie
jetzt ansprachen also wie wie krieg ich
sozusagen das system dahin dass menschen
auch bei ihrem hausarzt oder bei dem
sich einfach wirklich beraten lassen
können bevor sie in ein impfzentrum
gehen um sich genau aus erster hand und
da wo sie vielleicht auch das vertrauen
entsprechend dazu haben das bekommen
also was müsste was müsste sozusagen im
gesundheitswesen passieren wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe
damit dieses pfund das mandat besser
genutzt werden kann
ja also ärzte auch pfleger unglaublich
viele pflegende in deutschland die sind
ganz ganz wichtige multiplikatoren und
wir sehen dass in manchen bundesländern
bereits auch breit in den medien das
staatlichen gewissen zögerlichkeit gab
sich impfen zu lassen
und da glaube ich ist eine chance vertan
worden vielleicht ist es auch noch nicht
zu spät
das eine ganz wichtige gruppen die ganz
spezifisch informiert werden müssen die
haben vielleicht spezifischen fachfragen
als die allgemeinbevölkerung
und da wird schon einiges gemacht es
gibt frage antwort runden mit sparen und
kohl speziell für ärzte online und so
weiter aber das und ist in die frage wer
kümmert sich eigentlich um diese fragen
beantwortet die und wer startet am diese
wichtigen berufsgruppen mit dem info
material aus was sie brauchen sowohl für
ihre eigene entscheidung aber auch für
die beratung ihrer patienten und
patientinnen und ihres freundeskreises
denn jeder der jemanden aus dem
gesundheitssystem als freund und
freundin hat wird da mal fragen wie
hältst du's mit dem von katrina schreibt
via facebook man kann die menschen nur
erreichen wenn man deren sorgen ernst
nimmt haben sie das gefühl dass das
schon hinreichend passiert oder gibt es
einen wie auch immer gearteten im druck
den sie verspüren oder was sie da
vielleicht messen in den umfragen und in
den studien die sie betreiben dass es
vielleicht sogar kontraproduktiv ist
dass da so eine art mentaler druck
aufgebaut wird oder ist es tatsächlich
so dass das es nur darum geht die sorgen
überhaupt erst mal ernst zu nehmen da
sich auch auf augenhöhe zu begeben und
die menschen da klarer mitzunehmen
ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger punkt
das wird auch immer wieder in der
aufklärung gegen mit ärzten betont oder
auch insgesamt aufklärung dass das
ernstnehmen der sorgen um ganz wichtiger
punkt ist denn die leute möchten sich
schützen sie möchten sich vor einem
gefährlichen krankheit schützen aber sie
möchten natürlich dafür auch keine
unkontrollierbaren risiken eingehen
deswegen muss man diese sorgen ernst
nehmen und es sind ja auch über den
entstehungsprozess die herstellung und
so weiter sehr viele fragen aufgetaucht
jetzt aber weit auch schon von der
presse und auch von auf der regierungs
website und so weiter beantwortet werden
bezüglich dieses impfstoffs ist es
tatsächlich so dass diese so genannte
soziale norm natürlich wirkt also wenn
alle in meinem umkreis sagen ebenfalls
gut und sollte sich impfen lassen
dann bin ich auch eher bereit außerdem
hat impfen natürlich immer eine soziale
komponente wenn ich mich
schützt dann kann ich im idealfall eine
krankheit noch nicht auch nicht mehr
weitergeben
es ist jetzt bei den formal nicht ganz
klar ob das ja auch der fall sein wird
aber trotzdem reduziere ich auf jeden
fall erstmal die krankheitslast das
heißt es gibt immer so eine soziale
komponente und man geht mit der impfung
sozusagen einen sozialvertrag ein also
ich schätze mich auch für dich und dann
möchte ich gerne dass du dich auch für
mich schützt dass es beim impfen sehr
häufig der fall
und was wir beobachten ist dass zum
beispiel wenn man jetzt sagt gibt es so
eine art zwang oder sonntagen sozialen
doch sehen wir schon dass die
möglichkeiten dass zum beispiel
immunisiert also egal ob sie natürlich
die krankheit durchgemacht haben oder
games sind das den keine sonderrechte
oder sonder pflichten zu beschrieben
werden sollten also haben wir sehr lange
in der animierten beobachtet und das ist
sieht sich eigentlich durch
es soll keine sonderrechte oder
-pflichten geben für im monat also von
daher denke ich ist es auch sagen wir
mal diese in pflicht durch die hintertür
sowie das immer mal wieder betitelt
wurde darf man nur geimpft fliegen zum
beispiel oder in clubs
das wird zumindest nicht bereit
befürwortet ein anderes thema die
impfbereitschaft ist ich sag mal
vorsichtig besonders niedrig dort wo die
zahlen besonders hoch sind sachsen
beispielsweise ist das schlusslicht was
die impfbereitschaft anbetrifft und da
sind die infektions hohe zahlen
dramatisch hoch es ist nicht der osten
weil wie gesagt mecklenburg vorpommern
oder in sachsen anhalt das sieht es
anders aus was auch impfbereitschaft
anbetrifft aber ich sag mal in
bestimmten regionen wo auch bestimmte
politische überzeugungen sehr stark
vertreten sind fällt die ablehnung schon
auf ist das auch teil ihrer studie haben
sie da auch erkenntnisse die politischen
neigungen der befragten nicht angeben
speziell wirklich nur die
psychologischen hintergründe und
angucken wollen wollen nicht dass es
politisch sozusagen
in die eine oder andere richtung gedreht
wird wir sehen natürlich schon dass ich
sag mal so was wie verschwörungs glauben
das hängt schon auch vor der panini mit
geringer impfbereitschaft zusammen
ich glaube was wir in sachsen auch sehen
müssen ist es da sehr große ausbrüche in
einem pflegeheim bahn und david zuerst
geimpft
ich glaube bis jetzt galt die maßgabe
auch dass dort nicht geimpft wird wo
gerade ein ausbruch stattfindet und das
wäre jetzt im moment einem mann ein
prothesen auch dass das möglicherweise
auch die durch impfungen etwas reduziert
es gibt jetzt einen vorstoß auf über das
rkw dass man das doch tun sollte auch
dort wo eben ein ausbruch gerade
stattgefunden hat oder nur wenige fälle
sind also es könnte sein dass das
nochmal vielen weiß noch mal einiges
ändert jetzt ändert sich ja vielleicht
auch wenn man in einer region lebt wo es
besonders viele zahlen gibt auch die die
eigene haltung dazu zumindest ist das
mal eine these die ich mal aufstellen
je mehr infekte es gibt desto näher
kommt es mir vielleicht auch also man
kennt einen der infizierte sind der
familie ist vielleicht jemand oder im
freundeskreis ist jemand für das
vielleicht auch zu einem umdenken oder
welche erkenntnisse haben sie da so ist
sehr klassisch sozusagen die
risikowahrnehmung die dadurch
beeinflusst wird auch so die gefühlte
risikowahrnehmung und das ist eigentlich
dass es unser verhalten oft treibt wir
sehen aber über die gesamte partie
hinweg sehen wir dass wir uns sehr stark
auch an die panini gewöhnen also jetzt
wo eigentlich sehr viele fälle gerade
stattfinden ist unser risiko war nämlich
wesentlich höher als die kinder an
und das finden so gewöhnungsprozess
statt das heißt es ist nicht das
alleinige wir haben auch viel im umgang
mit der pandemie gelernt gott sei dank
wird uns jetzt sicher nicht auch noch
weile noch begleiten
von daher ist die risikowahrnehmung
wichtig aber hier nicht der einzige
treiber also menschen wegen hier gerade
bei der impfung risiken gegner
da ab und wenn man natürlich sie dass
viele im umfeld passiert auch gerade bei
jüngeren leuten vielleicht was jetzt
immer mehr auftritten die longo mit
erscheinungen also ist man auch noch
nicht so schwerwiegenden verläufen
langfristig davon betroffen jetzt mit
unangenehmen nachfolgen das könnte ich
mir vorstellen ist das dazu führt dass
auch im jüngeren semestern damit
zurückführt abschließend noch die frage
ist wird sicher verändern die kurve geht
nach oben bei den impfungen es wird
menschen geben die machen es auch
überzeugt davon und andere die lehnen
das ab das wird sich nicht ändern die
frage ist wie das verhältnis ist der
sozusagen zahlenmäßig aber jetzt das wo
ich darauf hinaus will auch inhaltlich
also was wird auch in der kommunikation
dazu führen zwischen denen die sich
bereitwillig impfen lassen die er damit
auch vielleicht eine erwartung
ihrerseits ausdrücken dass es andere
auch machen um diese herdenimmunität von
60 70 prozent in deutschland auch zu
erreichen und den dies partout nicht
machen wollen als er traditionsgemäß wir
in deutschland so was wie zwischen drei
und fünf prozent die sagen ich den
impfung grundsätzlich ab die wird man es
hier sicherlich auch haben
das bezieht sich immer auf intel
allgemein und natürlich auch auf info
movie schon sehr viel mehr erfahrung mit
haben
ich denke man muss sich klar machen dass
bis leute dran sind die unter 60 sind
und jetzt nicht in einem besonderen
risiko bereich arbeiten sind schon ich
glaube 27 millionen menschen zweimal
geimpft wenn die sich alle impfen lassen
das heißt da wird es sehr sehr sehr viel
erfahrung geben ist die breite
bevölkerung nah dran kommt und ich denke
diese erfahrung ist wichtig die zu
kommunizieren viel info sind am haben
stattgefunden welche nebenwirkungen
aufgetreten und da gibt es große
anstrengungen gehe dann betrieben werden
mit einer eigens eingerichteten ebwo
nebenwirkungen monitor werden man kann
es als auf der seite ist von ehrlich
instituts nachlesen und das dadurch dass
das so transparent gehandhabt wird denke
ich wird man das sehr gut einschätzen
können wie groß letztendlich der anteil
derer ist die am ende sagen ich will das
partout nicht haben
das
kann man jetzt glaube ich nicht seriös
abschätzen und es wird sich zeigen ob
will die ihr herdenimmunität in dem
umfang erreichen werden und das gilt
aber natürlich nicht nur für unser
achtes wird dann alles in den großen
kontext muss es gedacht werden wir
müssen auch nicht nur unseren kontinent
denken dass afrikanische länder durch
geimpft sind wird es auch noch eine
weile dauern wird erhebliche anstrengung
brauchen und ich denke dass wenn wir uns
erstmal ins gedanken gewöhnt haben wird
es auch ein thema sein das sollte
dringend auf unserer tagesordnung stehen
wir nur wenn alle ausreichend geimpft
sind können wir irgendwie global uns
wieder so frei bewegen gibt es vorher
getan haben
eine sache noch vielleicht abschließend
es gibt viele kommentare wenn ich hier
schauen bei montech wolle seine
mitarbeiter nicht impfen lassen
auch da muss man glaube ich dazu sagen
dass das nicht stimmt das ist eine
klassische falschmeldung
der chef von bei unter persönlich hatte
es übrigens bei den kollegen von der ard
gesagt dass er sich natürlich liebend
gern impfen lassen will allerdings es
gibt dann natürlich rechtliche
grundlagen die beachtet werden wollen
und an die man sich halten muss denn wir
haben in deutschland eine klare im
freien folge die gilt auch für
mitarbeiter von bayer am tag da gibt es
keine keine extrawurst
auch das muss man vielleicht mal an der
offen aussprechen
abschließend es geht hier nicht wie
gesagt darum werbung zu machen sondern
es geht darum die menschen zu verstehen
in ihren gedanken die sie haben haben
sie trotzdem so etwas wie ein appell
nicht nur an diejenigen die überlegen
sich impfen zu lassen oder nicht sondern
vielleicht an diejenigen die dafür
verantwortlich sind diese
impfbereitschaft in deutschland höher
werden zu lassen was bringen zu beachten
ist damit wir da eine bessere
diskussionskultur bekommen ja das sind
ja verschiedene player also ist denn
einmal natürlich die politiker und das
sind die medien und ich glaube das eine
ist wenn man mit den medien anfangen
es wird ja oft in der
medienberichterstattung gesagt wir
machen den ausgewogenen bericht und
suchen einen der ist dafür und einen der
ist dagegen
und es führt dazu dass es zu einer
ganzen
herten darstellung der meinung kommt
aber wir sehen das auch in der
wissenschaft ist die überwiegende
mehrzahl der wissenschaft klar diese
impfung befürwortet auch mittlerweile
ist es so dass die überwiegende mehrzahl
der menschen diese impfung befürwortet
und wenn man dann eins zu eins auswählt
sozusagen verzerrt das einfach das bild
und sowas schuldnachweis ist zu
unsicherheit und da wünsche ich mir
eigentlich sehr dass dieses thema der
impfmüdigkeit oder der skeptizismus oder
sagen wir mal dass impfgegner ton nicht
so um künstlich herbeigeschrieben oder
herbeigerufen wird wie das manchmal der
fall ist das wäre das eine
die medien haben einfach eine sehr sehr
große verantwortung gut zu informieren
dagegen sagten radio im fernsehen sind
die medien die am stärksten war
gewünscht werden und zur aufklärung
eines anderen wenn die politiker da
fällt es uns ja meistens immer leichter
darüber nachzudenken wenn es in der
ferne ist also diese maßnahmen so kann
den hebel kämpfen sollten nicht
politisiert werden in eine maske tragen
in amerika denken das war lange ein
zeichen dafür ob man für oder gegen
schwamm und das hat der panel bekämpfen
gut getan und so ähnlich müssen wir das
hier auch sehen dass impfen sollte nicht
ein politikum werden
es gibt sicher nicht immer irgendwie
kremann in dem prozess das ist natürlich
ein wahnsinns historische prozess nicht
alles läuft reibungslos aber ich glaube
jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass zum
möglichst nicht politisiert wird auch
ausflüge gegen insel ist jetzt in dem
fall gegen korona sollte mich mit
gewählt werden das glaube ich sind wir
richtig
von elisabeth vielen dank für ihre zeit
und für diese information live aus
erfurt danke dafür
das war's für heute bei zdf heute live
wir haben es gehört
es gibt noch viel zu tun nicht nur was
die beschaffung anbetrifft auch was die
verteilung anbetrifft und natürlich auch
was die überzeugungsarbeit anbetrifft
und wie gerade gehört die
diskussionskultur in der hoffnung dass
2021 einen anderen verlauf nimmt als
2020 sagen wir danke für euer interesse
danke für eure teilhabe und diesmal
[Musik]